(mellow music)
(people chatting)
(instruments tuning)
- [Yuel] Should we just
double-check our (mumbles)?
(instruments tuning)
(chamber music)
- I think there's a lot of
things going on that are
driving people to
experiment, and to explore,
and to hunger for something different.
It's a very interesting time in history
where people are beginning to see
the old system isn't working.
Not only economically,
ecologically, but in human terms.
- You can look at cooperation
as an ethical, good-hearted thing.
Or you can look at it as
something people need to do
to take their work seriously,
to take other people seriously,
to organize politically.
This isn't touchy feely stuff,
this is about actually
getting the world to work.
- We're in transition,
and what's remarkable to
me is that people feel that
in their bones.
We need to figure out how to align
the human economy with the
principles and patterns
that tend to operate
in all living systems.
That's the essence of it.
And so, the challenge is to kind of
figure out how to switch
out the engines on the plane
while we're keeping the plane in the air.
(chamber music)
- What if we were able to
really build the foundations
of a cooperative world?
What would it look like?
What would be free and exciting?
What would be generous?
What would be moral?
What would be exciting?
What would be liberating?
That's the kind of direction
we're talking about.
We're at ground zero beginning to explore
designs that take us beyond the
20th century capitalism,
20th century socialism.
There are a lot of people beginning to say
there's gotta be a better way.
You talking about changing the system,
the whole system?
That's what this is about,
but that means people have to really
start small but also, think big.
(mellow music)
- Housing is one of the
primary social institutions.
We have an opportunity
through technology and
kind of open collaborative
philosophies that have been
emerging in the last few years
to really rethink the way that
the built environment works
and the way that major
societal structures work.
I have to instigate the project
that we're sitting in right now.
It's called the Red Victorian,
and it's a 20-room hotel,
and it's a bed and breakfast,
it's been here for 100 years.
We took it over about a year ago,
and turned it into what we're
calling a co-living hotel.
The Red Victorian is really
a new way of thinking
about home and housing
in the 21st century.
It's a combination of
long term residential accommodations but
in a very fluid way with
short term housing options.
So, we have people staying
here everywhere from one night
to one month to indefinitely.
We're aiming to serve the kind of modern,
nomadic creative population
and so, people are often traveling,
or they're working late,
or their schedules are very different.
We don't have a particular hierarchy,
and I certainly wouldn't call myself
the boss or the manager,
or we're all managers,
or you can think of it
in many different ways,
but it's a cooperatively run space.
- [Man] Okay, which one are we looking at?
- [Woman] Can I show you something?
- [Man] Sure.
- The way we make decisions
at the Red Victorian is
open to everybody who's in the community.
I went and I met with the
Department of Public Health,
and they provided a couple of options for
what we could do in the
short term to be compliant
with what health codes are required.
So, the first is that
we could be officially
a bed and breakfast,
providing the breakfast
and other things that go along with that.
It means that only
employees and innkeepers,
which they don't even know
what they're defined as,
may provide food for the guests,
but we have to provide it,
and the guests can't provide it,
can't access it themselves.
- That's so, silly 'cause it like
precludes you from doing
new and innovative stuff.
- We basically don't fit
into any of the boxes
that they have for anything.
They could basically say
you've gotta shut down your hotel
because you're not complaint.
- We're witnessing an era where
the diversity of economies
are starting to flourish
and so, government
doesn't know what to do.
- But this seems to be
written for like a B&B
that's family run.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is what I'm seeing here.
- Family run bed and breakfast,
that's a thing right?
- Yeah.
- But yeah that's, that's actually...
It turns out a co-living
hotel is a family run
bed and breakfast.
Who knew?
- Easy.
- Thanks everyone for coming tonight.
This is our Wednesday
dinner at the Red Victorian.
For those of you who may
not have been here before,
the Red Vic is our home.
(people chatting)
- [Jessy Kate] I'm
really inspired by living
around and being exposed to people
who are up to amazing things in the world.
We can provide an
environment and a structure
that not only selfishly gets
us exposed to those people,
but actually,
I think supports and amplifies
the work that they're doing
by making it easier for them
to do what they're doing
and also, to hopefully meet others
who are inspiring to them.
- We've been totally
bootstrapped up to this point.
- I mean I think that this
to me
a very exciting aspect of
having a physical building,
is that it's an opportunity to provide
literally a container for
a whole bunch of humans
to walk through the door,
and when you walk through that door,
we get to say hey the rules are
a little bit different here.
We really like to play
with that in terms of
having people getting to say
actually here you do have a say in things,
and then looking at it and saying,
okay well how's that working?
Actually that didn't work very well
but that worked really well,
okay let's update how we're doing things
and try it again and instead
of it's a big experiment.
(chamber music)
- I first really understood
about cooperation
because my background is as a musician
and of course when we play chamber music
or any kind of music that
doesn't have a conductor,
we have to find ways to cooperate.
You know the way most musicians rehearse
is by grunts
or eye contact you know or
grimaces.
(chamber music}
- Like being able to really
listen to the other person,
all three of them in fact,
you're kind of trying to hear
three voices in your head at the same time
as you're looking at your own
music and playing together so,
you kind of get into the flow as a group.
Do you know what, I think we
need to practice number 1,
just right from there, from 1 to 2.
Yeah, why don't we try one at a time.
Why don't you do it once with her from 1?
- Yeah, we are part of
one thing and you know
each one of us have a role
and sometimes we trade in roles.
It's a real conversation,
well, reminiscent of life.
It's communicating.
It's fun.
(chamber music)
- We are on about 1 1/2
acres of urban land.
It was a parking lot
and through a partnership
with Concord Pacific
we have been able to farm this land.
So, we are an urban farm.
- We felt certainly a great
need on the downtown east side
that nothing agricultural was going on,
that a social enterprise
based on agriculture
had the potential to not
only provide meaningful work,
but also, a number of
other healing aspects
that occur by nature of working the soil,
growing living things,
taking care of something,
feeding other people.
So, we have five farms, each is different.
They each are in different neighborhoods.
They each are doing different things.
This is an orchard for example.
Pacific and Carol, our largest site,
big production,
and First and Clark an entire acre,
16,000 square feet
of unheated tunnel houses.
You know where we're
producing tomatoes and peppers
and melons and things like that.
So, we have to, because of the,
intensity and scale of the
operation, we have to make
maximum use of time and space.
So, as soon as a crop is done, boom,
replant, you know.
Here people using these
words urban agriculture.
Nobody had ever heard
those two words together,
when I would describe
it, it was like what?
And we felt we needed to demonstrate
that it was possible to
have a successful enterprise
business based on agriculture in the city
and at the same time support
people's needs.
We had to bring the farm to the city.
Yeah, we had to create within these boxes
an entire ecosystem.
Kinda crazy,
imperfect,
but has potential.
- We are providing employment to people
who are facing barriers.
Sometimes that's an addiction,
sometimes that's a mental illness,
sometimes it's a physical illness.
Whatever the barrier,
it makes it hard for
most of our staff to work
a regular job.
They need a job where there's
flexibility and understanding
about the ups and downs of their lives.
- Right there, lemon tree
with lemons,
right?
That's special.
It's awesome yeah, yeah.
I missed my calling, man.
I should have been a fucking gardener,
instead of what I was.
It's not very often down here
'cause you know you're
pretty rough around the edges
that you get to care and
nurture for something.
When I was a kid, punishment
was going to weed the garden.
so, when I came here it's
like, oh man what am I doing.
I remember this.
But it's not like that.
You get into the soil and stuff.
You get to see stuff grow and, actually,
it's kind of beautiful.
It is beautiful, it's not kinda
beautiful, it is beautiful.
- Sole Food has two primary goals.
One is the a social one,
and I think one is an agricultural one.
The social one is first and foremost.
The agricultural one
dominates and then forms the social piece.
This as a community,
this is a place to go,
this is a reason to get up in the morning.
This has a choice between
something that's gonna bring you down
and something that might be positive.
This is where you're getting
hung up on right here.
- 'Cause these guys, they
don't give up on you.
You don't show up, you're
not feeling too good,
you're not making it,
come back the next day,
we'll keep working.
You don't get fired here.
And hey, I come in every day.
Oh, I missed one day last month
and that's the only day I missed.
I do all the seeding here just about.
Yeah I guess I'm the boss for here.
Tell people where they need to be,
what needs to get done
and stuff like that,
but it's only my second
year and I'm still learning,
and I'm learning from the best.
Lissa is a beast.
She might be small, she's strong too.
She can work her butt off.
- [Michael] She's awesome.
She really kinda holds
us all together for us.
And she's a good weeder.
- Thanks Michael.
At least I know I can't mess that up.
Why do I do this?
Some days I don't know. (laughing)
I mean we all want the
world to be a better place
and I think that there's real,
for me personally, there was
a lot of transformative power
in agriculture in my life.
I come from a really privileged world.
I went to university
which was paid for
primarily by my parents.
I grew up in a stable household
with a really loving family.
I had people all along telling
me that I could do things.
It is quite hard coming in this.
You try to find a common
ground with people.
I don't know what it's like to
go through opiate withdrawal.
I don't know what it's
like not be able to get
my prescription in the morning
when I need it every day.
There's days when like I
really can't understand
what someone's dealing with
but you can be compassionate.
(mellow music)
- A lot of people on the east side
are great people,
it's just that they don't
think that they're worth
the puddle that they're stepping in,
and that's the truth, right?
I've been a heroin addict
for about 20 years.
I battle with addiction and
it didn't matter to them.
Like it didn't matter to them.
You know I had track
marks, it didn't matter.
I wasn't being judged, you know, like
what's going on here right?
- [Michael] The power
of what we've done here
has to be shared,
both by the
influence
of the
soil and the plants and the healthy food,
but also, by the community of people who
have been involved with this experience.
It's about the people.
- What we see emerging is what we call
a regenerative economy,
and in very simple terms,
we're having this conversation
because our bodies have been,
and are continuing to regenerate.
So, we're sustainable
because we're regenerating,
and the whole universe works that way.
And we see it everywhere.
And usually driven by the
intuition of an entrepreneur
who has no theoretical framework in mind.
They intuit it.
So, that's why I'm confident
that it's an emergent property,
and it's amazing
how often we see these
patterns repeating themselves.
(mellow music)
- The London Brewing Cooperative
is located in London's old east village.
Tight community, vibrant community,
a community that's really
has its own identity
and is moving forward.
- I suppose it's got its roots in
my friend Marcus receiving
a used book for his birthday
Papazian's
New Complete Joy of Home Brewing
and he sent me an email and
said hey you wanna brew beer?
And I liked beer.
I had no idea it could be made.
- We were brewing together
you know in my garage
just with you know something we built.
It was a propane-fired,
gravity-fed system.
I mean we didn't paint
it up even to look nice.
It was very utilitarian,
it made beer, it made very good beer.
Everybody has a good
time brewing the beer.
Everybody has a good time
sitting around and chatting.
And usually beer brings
out some good debate,
brings people together.
- It was a very makeshift system
that we had you know thrown together and
garage door wide open so the
propane fumes could go out
and you know we were just having
a lot of fun brewing beer.
We started to realize
these recipes are actually
people kinda like them
and it's starting to work.
- And we looked at different models of
cooperative brewing,
ways that a brewery could both be
financially viable but
also be collectively owned.
We couldn't figure it out,
so we just kept brewing,
but we just enlarged the circle.
At that point it was myself, Dave...
Dave often jokes that he got involved
'cause he had a garage.
That's partially true.
- [Gar] I think people want
to be on big decisions that matter.
How to structure that
becomes really tricky.
We have to learn that, it
doesn't come naturally.
A cooperative is simply
a one person, one vote
ownership structure.
So, you get a group of people together,
everybody gets a vote,
and you set up a company or
a bank or a store or a farm.
It's a very simple structure.
- We purposely located
ourselves in old east village.
It's a neighborhood we love,
it's a neighborhood
that many of us live in
and so, we want to be
part of that community.
So, we don't want to have a huge
you know pollution
spewing kind of operation.
We wanna have a community brewery
so, one that everybody
feels they can be a part of,
everyone feels that
is doing things that
are in the best interest
of the community.
- Co-ops, I mean, they're
a very old business model,
they're an underutilized, business model,
and at the premise they're about a more,
equitable distribution
of power and wealth.
- If we can just make a couple of notes of
positive and then things
to improve on maybe?
- The idea is a very
beautiful one when you
think about how it can work
and how everyone works together.
- Do it on a night that,
like on a Friday or a
Saturday night potentially,
when we're gonna be busy in the cellar.
- It's one member one vote.
It's not $1 one vote.
So, it doesn't matter how
much of the company you own,
how much you have invested,
it's that you have a stake in the outcome.
- That's a food house,
that's a real food house.
- So, there's no need for a president,
there's no need for a secretary,
but they say no, no you need to have one,
what kind of corporation
doesn't have a president?
- So, it's about engagement.
It's about folks having control
over the workplace
as much as they also,
end up in a position of the workplace
having control over them right?
- At the end of the day
we're people helping people
and I think that's how a lot of
my coworkers view this job
and if you're coming into this job
from a non-cooperative structure,
then it can be very different,
but I do think it encourages folks to
view their work differently
and therefore work in a different way.
- We're not taught to cooperate,
and we're not taught to trust.
Think of all the board games
that we play when we were kids.
I just remember playing
with my cousins and you got,
Monopoly,
it's about being at the top.
- Working together is--
- Working together is
really hard. (laughs)
When everyone has...
I mean the purpose of a worker co-op is
democracy between workers.
So, when everyone has an equal voice,
it can be difficult to reach a consensus.
But yeah, basically human
interaction is hard,
especially when there's
not a hierarchy saying
you know, I'm the manager,
this is what we're gonna do.
- [David] We can all work together
for somebody else's goals.
So, cooperation to me means
deciding on those goals together,
and maybe the benefit of
having a brewery is that
you get together and you have kind of that
Habermasian cafe style
where everybody debates.
That's the democracy,
and not a voice that's just
understood through a vote,
but a true voice at the table.
- Well we're having a baby in
a few months.
- 4 1/2 months.
- Yep, really soon, coming up really fast.
You know this has
brought another aspect of
long term planning into our co-op meetings
and the development of our co-op.
What does maternity leave look like?
Well, we have to decide that right?
What does paternity leave look like?
Is it going to be possible for me
to step away from my daily job for
three, four months, maybe longer?
Which brings us to another complication,
which is where do we find more people
with the you know the vision that we have,
the dedication we have to our work?
- Who was I speaking to the other day,
they said never get in
business with your friends
and it's just like
I don't know who I'd
wanna work with otherwise
because if they don't know you,
if they don't know your story,
then how do they understand
where you're coming from?
It's running at 100, though
with just one element.
- 100 with one is (mumbling).
But I thought a couple
boilers is all right.
(baby crying)
- [David] It can be a
real difficulty to be
cooperative at all times, right?
To work in a democratic way
and to make sure that everyone's on board.
How long does it take to--
- It takes 40 minutes in total.
- [David] You know it's, again
a real reality in a corporate world.
You have a child and you
need to take time off?
You're falling behind.
- Do you wanna baby piece of toast?
- It might be easier to do if it were
just a straight up business sometimes,
if you didn't have to
deal with relationships
and you didn't have to
deal with cooperation
you might be able to do something
that was far more efficient,
than what we have but it wouldn't,
we wouldn't be the ones doing
it, it'd be somebody else.
- Well, I had kinda come to,
I guess like the end of my rope
with job hunting and had
applied for several things
and wasn't really getting anywhere
and saw this job posting
and then I was like oh well somebody who
knows how to work with
food and can talk to chefs.
I'm like, well that's
pretty much what I've
been doing my whole life so,
that job has got my name
written all over it.
I guess technically I'm a sales person
but maybe this is why I'm good at sales
is 'cause I don't like sales.
I just let the quality of
what we do speak for itself,
and they either want it
or they don't want it.
I don't wanna sell something
to someone who doesn't want it.
It's dishonest.
- My job is what I call quality control.
So, I mean everything you see here
I make sure that
I go through everything
before it comes here so,
that means everything's
as best as possible
and as perfect as possible.
So, one of the things that
Sole Food's always been about,
it's always been about quality.
We will not put anything out
that we wouldn't take ourselves
or more likely better than
we would eat ourselves.
- Another bonus I get that
some people don't get,
I get to work the market.
So, I see that finished product
and then I see the people
that are buying that product
for a really good price
and how happy they are with it.
People are happy with our
product and I love that.
- One thing that's so great
about Sole Food Farms is
I think that they know their community.
They know their neighborhood.
That's why it's important
that they're nearby,
that's why, another thing
why we choose them is
they get it.
You know they understand the
difficulties that we have.
We're very, very small first of all
and every day the menu's different.
It's what's ever in
season, whatever's fresh,
whatever they're proud of they send to us
and then we use that as inspiration.
- [Michael] It's embodied in how you feel
when you've done this work.
How you feel when you see somebody
who's eaten the food
and comes back and tells
you how incredible it is.
Those are the things
that are so intangible
and so difficult to put a value on.
You had those before?
- My first time.
- Oh man let me see what you've got here.
Oh yeah, that's gonna be good.
(mellow music)
These overpasses,
they're gonna come down in four years
and when they do, where we sit right now,
where there's these
wonderful crops growing,
the carrots and the
radicchio and the arugula and
parsleys and whatever's here
will be replaced with high rises
and people will be living on this land
where we sit right now
20 or 30 stories up
as far
from this
as you can possibly get.
- [David] So, what we're doing today is
going up and down the corridor
in the old east village
which is where we wish to
maintain our presence as a brewery
looking at potential spaces.
- [Realtor] Okay, so
there's no light up here
so, you have to be careful
and watch your step.
- Right now, we're in a lease situation
so, if we could potentially
purchase a building,
if that makes more sense
either sharing it with
other businesses, et cetera,
that's what we're interested in doing.
So, we're kinda doing walk throughs.
Like there was work done.
- At some point.
- At some point here.
- [Aaron] Not that long ago.
- [David] At least it's easy to find
where the roof is leaking.
There's a lot of opportunities,
a lot of options
and we're trying to just determine,
what options are in fact opportunities
and what may be money pits if you were.
- The second level's been renovated.
I put $75,000 in it, brand new.
- I mean that, it would be the,
it's the skateboard
co-op main floor right?
Skateboard co-op on the main floor?
- [Owner] Yeah, yeah.
- [Jeff] What, what is the next one down?
- 658?
- Yeah
- Yeah, let's go you wanna see it?
- 'Cause we like the skateboard co-op,
they're good guys.
We don't wanna mess
around with their spot.
- Oh no, they're cool,
I already got a spot for them.
They actually might go there
regardless if you buy it or not.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
'Cause they wanna go over there.
We've already talked about it.
I spoke to them about
it a couple weeks ago.
- Oh, that building?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you want it, they're
taken care of, trust me.
I love those guys.
- Come on in everybody.
We're here to stay as long as we can stay.
- That's what we said.
We're like we don't even wanna look at it
if you guys are staying.
- Oh he's trying to get you
guys to buy the building too?
- Well yeah that's news.
- Yeah well no, no.
The whole thing is is this
is the building we want.
- Yeah that's awesome
and we support that 100%.
So, we'll stop looking right now.
- Yeah we wanna stay here.
There's a chance that if it
doesn't work out for us here
that we'll try to get the
Father and Sons building but
this is 100% like--
- Where you wanna be.
- Yeah man.
- Oh, dude let's...
Now we're just on a tour.
Yeah that's what we were
just told that out back.
We're like what?
He's like, sorry man we didn't know that.
Well yeah, but a certain level of honesty.
It's a chance for us to
start talking about this
landlord nonsense.
- Yeah.
- The owners of these buildings, come on.
- So, interesting day.
We did a bunch of stuff
and we're planning on
making a ramp tonight.
- Like Jim's like what
are you guys doing here?
No, we want this building.
Like ah come on, these guys
are friends, that's not good.
So, we gotta clean that up.
- You need small businesses
that may not have a ton of
capital in order to buy it
to at least have a
responsible expectation that
the building won't be
swept out from under them
as soon as it becomes
profitable to somebody else.
- This neighborhood
provides a real opportunity
in that it can become,
if we want it to be,
it can become a place
where all are accepted
where we have a mixed neighborhood
where people from all income brackets,
all walks, all backgrounds
have a capacity to interact,
and build a good life.
That's what we're aiming for.
There are some pretty big
obstacles in our way and
quite directly it's those
who control the property
are in our way.
- [David] It's not money, I mean money is,
it's a necessity in this world,
but that's truly not the relationships
we're trying to build.
- Collaboration is ultimately
the more sustainable approach
than competition,
whereas of course our
competitive capitalist system,
in Wall Street no more than anywhere,
is rooted in the idea that you know this,
this false understanding of Darwin.
What Darwin said is the fittest...
In fact he didn't even coin the term
survival of the fittest,
but the way he used it is
fittest as in the one that fits best
within the whole system,
not the, the strongest.
(mellow music)
- So, my name is Tiberius Brastaviceanu.
People know me as Tibi.
When I first came to
Canada I was 14 years old
and I went to University of Montreal
for a masters in Applied Physics.
Laser applications to
biology and (mumbles).
I work here at the Sensorica Lab.
Sensorica is this new
type of organization where
you're free to join,
and to take initiative
and start new projects.
It is a commercial venture,
and you work collaboratively with people.
You share the revenue according
to everyone's contribution.
It is a decentralized
network and there is no boss.
We focus on material production,
meaning hardware,
electronics, we put stuff together.
So, we're trying to solve how
material stuff could be
produced in an open way.
Sensorica started by focusing
on open source hardware
but on the high end side.
So, we said let's first
prove that open source
can produce scientific instruments.
Five years ago open source
hardware was just starting,
now we see drones and 3D printers.
These two industries are
driven by open source.
(machine whirring)
This is the main hub of the
network where things happen,
where hardware gets done,
prototyped, and produced.
There's other people working
from their own little
home labs around the world
that do some prototyping
and then we mirror it here.
We're democratizing here
access to the micron world.
Traditionally these pieces can cost you
tens of thousands of dollars.
Open source,
maybe 20% of the cost,
allow scientific labs in
universities in the emerging world
to do their science.
My background is in lasers, so
everything you see with
optics, optical fiber,
that's my contribution to the projects,
and the mechanical side
and the electronics part
these are other people that
have contributed to it.
It's a collaborative work, I think.
There's many different sections here.
So, this is our micro 3D printer
which will be used for
micro 3D chips design.
What we do, we add an optical fiber.
It's just the size of a little hair.
So, this is like a pen of light
that solidifies or polymerizes
the resin that you put inside,
and you're able to do tiny,
tiny, tiny structures.
It just needs a bit of integration,
but the proof of concept is done
so, that's something that will go on
crowd funding pretty soon.
The tiniest printer in the world. (laughs)
People here are motivated by
what's the next big thing we can work on
that can be so disruptive
from micro 3D devices
and democratizing testing
of food and water quality,
how to automate a garden,
how to automate a greenhouse.
Well, here's all the
electronics that you need
and the software to run it.
We affectionately call
this the iPot. (laughs)
A completely autonomous flower pot.
We have an atmospheric
temperature and humidity sensor
so, the plant knows if the air is dry
or if the air is very humid,
and it knows the temperature.
And here we have a light sensor
so, the plant knows when
to turn the LED off/on
based on how much light
it got during the day.
You know the scientific instruments
that reduce the cost of innovation allows
people in Africa, and
Asia, and South America
to catch up with scientific development,
so, I think we're highly motivated
by these kind of projects.
The real change happens when
economic relationships changed,
and so, then the idea was
let's set up new economic
organizations based on
these new principles
by respecting some fundamental principles
that were behind what
was already existing,
so, let's build the
enterprise of the future.
And that was the seed value
for the Sensorica network.
- First you have to
release all the air you have
so, you can jump into the water
and then you can try to
catch the stars by exhaling.
Breathing Games is a project
we started for children
with cystic fibrosis.
Blow, blow, blow, blow, or
you're gonna hit the banan.
Ah, you hit him.
It's really about making the therapy fun.
Having the therapy is quite the challenge
for chronic illnesses,
and about one person over two
doesn't do the therapy well.
It's an exercise they have to do daily,
so it's quite tedious and yeah boring.
So, the games make the,
the therapy fun but it also
gives the feedback to them
about you're breathing
too low or too high.
We just connect this medical
device to the computer
so, that we can use the data
for the game and for the research too.
For hospitals, it's costing at least
$1,500.
So, it's not something you
can have at home easily.
If we include all the
parts that we plan to add
such as the memory card
and the battery and so,
it would be about $200.
In a later phase, we
want to do a microchip
and it would reduce the
cost to maybe $60, $80.
- The cost of innovation
using open source is very low.
These products can be
10% of the market price.
So, you're sinking the
costs of innovation,
and you're taking away some
costs of production or assembly.
Here's the file, print it at your local
3D printing shop and then
put it together IKEA style.
It really reduces the costs of a product.
- With like open licenses,
someone could take this and improve it,
and re-share it.
- Once it's completed,
the how to is gonna be
put out to the world,
and anyone that has the
capacity to replicate
the device can do it?
- Yes.
- No cost?
But there's also, going to be potentially
a commercial aspect to it.
How's that gonna work?
- The question is open source hardware
a viable
you know business model?
You have something at home to
bake something, to bake bread?
- [Man] Oh yes I do.
- Everybody has right?
Why don't you make your own bread?
You find tons of recipes on the internet,
why don't you make it?
You know and then you
make money on convenience,
you say "I can source the
parts for you, put 'em in a bag
"and send them to you."
Open source how their businesses
also survive on services.
People are asking, "Yeah
but if you can't patent,
"how can you protect?
"People are gonna copy you."
- You might gather your
thing to protect your idea
and develop it,
okay but then you patent
it and you protect it,
what if tomorrow somebody
thinks of something that
you guys didn't think of
and improves it and all of the sudden
releases their new technology
that is better than yours
so, yours is obsolete.
So, your patent
is useless.
- This is a journey.
We're on a journey to figure this out.
I'm pretty confident that
the regenerative frame is the right frame
and a regenerative frame
means that a system
is self-organizing, self-refueling,
self-learning
and so, you know, we see it
in lots of projects in the world.
It is emergent.
- [Patricia] Did we mention not to
vibrate here or are we vibrating?
- No vibrato? No vibrato okay.
Yeah okay let's, maybe let's try that.
- You wanna try that?
- Yeah let's try that.
Let's try it from the top.
(chamber music)
- A good listener is somebody
who can understand meaning
beyond what people actually say.
Very few of us actually
can find right away
particularly the words that
we want to use
to explain what we mean.
And a good listening skill
is
the ability to sense
what's behind
what people obviously
say.
- If you're playing a faster tempo,
then we can't fit
together, it's not working.
- [Patricia] Yeah, and I
think Yuel's in between us,
so it's real hard for him too.
- Yeah well let's try
it again, see if we can
feel this a little bit
more together as a group.
(chamber music)
- If you were describing
Loomio to your brother,
I think you would say something like
Loomio is a simple technology
that enables people to
come together to talk an issue through,
generate ideas,
and come to a clear, shared
understanding together,
and a decision about what
action to take together.
The idea came out of our experience
during the Occupy movement
of the potential for
collaborative decision making.
When the process is well held,
it can be totally amazing
like transformative for people.
When diverse perspectives
continually fade into a
collaborative process,
you know groups can end up
making more intelligent decisions
than any individual would by themselves.
- At the Red Victorian we
invite many people to be part
of the decision making process
and the way that we do that
is we provide them a link to
Loomio.
I'd love to get people to chime
in in the next day or two.
Well yeah, in the next 24 hours
on the Loomio thread and
then at least I'll have some
kind of direction to start
a conversation with them.
Some things are decided fully on Loomio,
some things involved the
offline component as well.
For larger issues, we tend to
then take that Loomio conversation,
meet in person,
and kind of go over some of the nuances
as a group.
- Oh so, it's like do we
wanna take that battle on
as our own?
- So, when a discussion
gets to the point where
someone in the group thinks
hey, we can make a decision here.
I've got an idea, this is what
I think the group should do,
they can put up a proposal.
And so, you've got discussion
on the left of the screen
and decision making on the right
and a proposal always
has a time limit on it.
So, it always comes to a clear conclusion.
So, you've got this sort of divergence
in the discussion and then you converge
on a shared outcome, an agreed outcome.
People participate in a decision
by clicking one of four buttons.
So, you can either agree,
or you can sort of opt out or abstain,
or you can disagree,
which is like saying I don't
know that it's the best idea
but I'm not gonna stand
in the way of the group,
or you can block or raise a red flag,
which is saying like I think
this is a really bad idea,
I've got a serious concern
that I would like to be addressed
before we move forward with this.
- [Jessy Kate] I think that
Loomio is really interesting
for the fact that it creates space for
people to kind of take the time
to deal with their emotions,
and then process them often
in more constructive ways
by writing down what they're thinking.
- There's all kinds of awful
stuff that happens online,
bullying,
but Loomio's sort of designed with that,
I guess with this idea in mind that
if we design online
environments in a way that makes
certain types of behavior easier,
so, really fosters a sense of
respectful, constructive dialogue,
I mean it's really about people
coming together to achieve
a shared purpose in a way that works
for all of the people involved
and it's kind of that simple.
Little kids get this stuff.
You know, we have 12-year-old
kids using Loomio effectively
in their schools with parents and teachers
making decisions together.
- I think that Loomio really catalyzes
those kinds of conversations because
you pick up on those nuances,
and you start to see them.
And it's not just actually the technology,
it's the types of collaborative structures
that technology enables.
- This idea that we expect
democracy from our government
and we're totally fine with like
tyranny or dictatorship in our
workplaces for some reason,
even though that's where
we spend eight hours a day
for most of our lives.
I have a lot of hope that that's changing.
It feels like there's a real movement
building around changing it.
It's just people coming
together to achieve something
around the creation of value,
and the cooperative structure is,
we've found it to be
totally flexible enough
to have you know real room to move,
to be adaptive,
to set things up in a resilient way
that doesn't involve specialization,
and you're most effectively
served the social mission.
- [Tibi] Sensorica, we found a
system, which is the
value accounting system,
where we can log our time.
And as soon as we have finances,
we can use the log we created
to redistribute the money.
- Pizza number one.
Ladies and gentlemen, pizza number one.
- Sensorica is a network where
people can collaborate
on different projects
and the idea is that the system
that we have put in place
captures all these contributions
from different individuals
in the context of that particular project.
And then we decide how
to share the benefits.
- According to the value equation.
- According to a value equation
which is a social contract that we
make and we agree on
before the project starts.
So, there's 5% that goes actually
to sustain the infrastructure,
to sustain the labs okay?
So, let's take this little part here
and nobody eats this one right?
And now here's a guy that
contributed let's say
a quarter.
Our system allows anybody
in the world to contribute
as much or as little as they want.
So, somebody's gonna
get just a little piece
and that's fine.
Because this guy is probably
doing something else,
he's working on other projects,
and that's his little contribution.
Here I'm gonna take this piece.
I'm gonna be modest.
- So conservative.
- How I got to the participatory economy
is by having been shocked
with my previous job.
In 2006, I left Montreal
to the Silicon Valley
in San Francisco,
and this is where I got my first job
as an engineer in a company
manufacturing lasers.
I was very stimulated.
I put a lot of heart into the work,
and then 2008 financial crisis comes,
and then you see how people are treated
once they're not
an asset anymore.
So, I just got laid off
and kicked out essentially.
That led me to use the
internet to find solutions,
and I realized how much power
the internet can give to an
individual and to groups.
So, that frustration turned
into something constructive.
I got the pictures.
- [Man] Yeah I'm trying
to see if there's more.
Well you're, you're there are you there?
- [Tibi] When I first came to Canada,
I just knew a bit of English,
not much,
and I didn't speak French.
Canada was pretty open to
immigration from Romania back then.
I think the second
community that adopted us
was the Italian community.
We spoke Italian,
and they were more
established than Romanians
who were just arriving.
- [Man] So you started
here, what, bus boy first?
- Yeah, for sure, for sure.
I didn't speak French or English.
I just started working here.
And then slowly, slowly I
started to pick up orders.
Tarly was here every week.
- Those were the days my friend.
Beautiful days.
Now all of a sudden you got smart.
Whatever you do, I hope it makes a change.
- [Tibi] What do you think about change?
- If it comes from you
it's probably a good thing.
- What a beautiful day huh?
(speaking foreign language)
My father's place from in Romania,
it's the capital of watermelon.
So, this is something we eat every day.
- [Interviewer] Do you need help?
Do you need help eating it?
- Yes, yes go ahead.
It drives my mother
crazy the way we eat it.
(everyone chatting)
I knew the truth since I was young,
because my father was very open about it.
My father was imprisoned in
Romania when he was young.
He always stood up against the regime,
so I grew up in an
environment where, you know,
idealism comes first.
They're very, very supportive parents.
You know I'll be speaking
about what people have done
for society so it runs deep.
How do you say father in--
(speaking foreign language)
They just dropped everything
to flee the country,
and that was to give us a better future.
(chamber music)
- People actually come to this
kind of notion of,
and I call it building the next society,
building the next system.
They come to it from different reasons.
Some come out of a lot
of pain and poverty,
and excruciating difficulties.
Either try something new
or we're in real trouble
The other part of it I think is,
it's cultural but it's also, people
who really crave getting
away from individualism
somehow, but the hunger for
what community can bring.
(chamber music)
- Sometimes we can just
play through the music,
the first time's not so good,
but then even without words,
it evolves into something.
I mean we're just all giving
and taking at the same time.
(mellow music)
- The mother is in Thorncliffe Park.
We wanted to make this place
a better place for everyone.
I'm originally from India,
and one of my husband's friend,
he gave a tour of Thorncliffe Park,
and the first day itself
we felt home here.
The next day when we got up,
and we wanted to walk in the neighborhood,
we walked into the park,
and then we were really not
happy with the condition
of the park and all.
But when we are here,
we have to fix things.
We came to know about a lot of women who
live in this apartment buildings,
mostly the immigrant,
and they are doing businesses from home.
They bring stuff from
their home countries,
and then sell it to
their neighbor's friends
at a very good price,
and make a supplement
income for themselves.
(speaking foreign language)
- This is for your great grandchildren.
- When we come together we talk about,
oh this is our like backyard
because all years in back
home when we are living,
house always have backyard or front yard.
There in the building,
you don't have any backyard any private.
So we call this there is a backyard.
So, in backyard we have
to have some activity too.
- So, we thought that
this is a really good idea
to create a market.
This market will serve as a platform
for the vendors and these newcomer women
where they will feel confidence
and you know and it will also,
empower them build their self-esteem,
and build the clientele as well.
- This is the magic of storage.
What you think it will be inside?
You will afraid to go farther.
- [Sabina] The park
completely transformed.
People gathered,
they started looking from
their apartment buildings,
and we could see the change in the park.
- I'm making roti.
Roti in Persian we say this is naan,
and the dough for roti is different
because we add yeast for this one.
- [Sabina] The park serve
as a common space for them
where they meet immigrants
and new Canadians
and spend some good
time having tea, coffee.
That was the main goal.
- We are waiting, waiting
until Friday come.
When we, Friday come, we
come out just we enjoy.
There is something,
just because of market we come out.
- As in the new immigrants,
a lot of women go through
stress and isolation on
a regular basis.
And we thought like
this market would serve
as a stress relieving agent
or something like that where people feel
really good when they come outdoors.
- I mean it's good to
empower empowerment in womens
with support to get house,
to get your lands, yeah.
So, yeah there's the main goals
to empowering the women, ladies.
- Did you buy any tray for yourself?
Did you buy any canopy for yourself?
Next year I'll be (speaking
foreign language),
you won't be coming to the market.
There are challenges
and there are achievements, right?
We started with zero,
nothing in our hands.
But we had a strong vision.
We had that commitment to
give it to the community,
to return back to the community.
The community comes up
with their own ideas,
and all because they feel comfortable.
They feel, they see us as,
the part of their own self
which is really challenging for us to take
everyone's suggestion
to work on one thing,
but we do acts of the
suggestions, and we choose
how best
those things fit into what
we are really trying to do.
I mean looking at the bigger goal.
Her husband passed away recently,
and for her these are
the opportunities which
provide supplement income for her
to run her house, and she has kids,
and she has to look after them,
and the more over is when
she comes to the market,
she comes with the friends,
and they are supportive,
and you know they are
always there for her.
It's like a building family
kind of environment in the market,
and they're all friends
come to the market to eat
what she is making and they love doing it.
- Thank you enjoy.
- You know when I look at their faces,
I can see in their eyes, you know.
I can sense that happiness.
That is, I think, that's the
value this market is bringing.
It's emotionally.
Though there is definitely a
financial support for them,
but still it is like more about
building relationship, building trust.
- She is very nice
and she always support
us and this she bring,
thank you so, much.
- Aw, my pleasure.
(chamber music)
- Maybe there is no reward
when cooperation works well.
Maybe you're just in the process,
and the process is the reward.
There's something that's
innately satisfying about that.
(chamber music)
- Sorry, sorry can we do it again?
We didn't start together I don't know why.
If we weren't able to work together,
music itself would suffer,
and it would be, probably,
we wouldn't be able to communicate
effectively as a group.
The music might still sound like music,
but it just wouldn't be convincing.
We wouldn't have the organic quality
that we are always striving for.
(chamber music)
Should we just do it one
more time with Sungyong now?
And then I'll join in the
end 'cause my part's easy.
Yeah let's see how it works.
Here's our motor right
we have this engine,
then we have the car driver.
(chamber music)
- The process itself is...
You feel very satisfied, you
know you go through stages
and you come to a different result,
but all the stages, you know,
it's enjoyable.
- I would just say, it's a lot more fun.
There's certain times
when you have to play
like a soloist from the virtuosic passage
in every one of our parts.
And there's no leader, but
then we're all leaders, too.
It's just a great experience.
(chamber music)
- [Lyle] I don't know if
I was a bad guy or not,
but I definitely wasn't a good guy.
You know you gotta leave
that shit behind you
if you wanna grow right?
And so, that's what
I've been trying to do.
- The farms in themselves by
nature of what we're doing here
are kind of like the great equalizer.
If you're out there picking
radishes or filling boxes
or planting trees or...
It doesn't matter what your history is,
how much suffering you've been through,
it really levels you off.
- Yeah it was a good opportunity to get
into the giving back department a bit.
Working for your community a bit, right,
instead of taking from it all the time.
- It wasn't a big idea that
we were gonna go out and
rescue people.
Our idea was set the table here,
and do it with
soil and seeds and growing food,
and allow that
process to do
what it does for all of us.
People ask me why I farm.
It's as much for my mental health
as it is for anybody
else who's working here.
I'm in no different.
We're different in some ways,
but we're all alike in other ways,
we all have our stuff.
- It is spiritual for me too.
Like you put something in
the, a seed in the ground,
ya nurture it,
ya care for it,
and it gives you something back.
Yeah it is something
actually that changes,
changes ya.
- We've survived a lot of crazy stuff,
but I think it's important enough
to the people who we work with
that it has to continue.
And it's important enough that
it has to include more people
who haven't been able to take part.
Our goal is not, unlike most
social service agencies,
is not to graduate people
and send them down the road.
No, we feel like
we want them to be
for as long as they want
to be able to come here.
- Yeah you guys are my family right?
- The first time I met this guy,
I was like who is this guy you know?
And you had kind of a hard edge.
- Well I wasn't very
like socially integrated either.
- Well you were new.
- Yeah, I was.
- [Michael] This guy's
got the softest core.
- You hear that guys?
That better be on tape man.
- He has a good heart.
He's got a good heart.
- I might need that one
day as character evidence.
- [Michael] That's right.
No I mean it, it blows my mind,
somebody who's gone
through the kind of shit
that you've gone through and that you're--
- Yeah I appreciate that Michael, I do.
- You guys don't have
the monopoly on suffering
by the way.
- Oh yes I know this.
- And so, I'm just saying, for me,
I needed to do this
for myself as much as for anybody else,
and that's the honest truth.
It's hard to admit but it's true.
I mean, I got my own
stuff I gotta deal with.
(chamber music)
- [Nikita] Actually, the
music is sort of like
a reflection of life.
This medium allows to have a conversation
with a different
people at different times,
and if it's works well,
it's really good. (laughs)
(chamber music)
- It's very clear to me that
to have a healthy system,
finance is a piece of the bigger whole,
and needs to be in service of that whole.
The basic premise of investment
is to invest money in order to
create more money at the end.
We call that return on capital,
but it's money in creating more money out.
So, we've grown a pile of money
while we've destroyed the atmosphere.
That's not sustainable.
- There's a whole sense is that
we've gotta go beyond just profit making,
which takes no regard for what
happens to the environment.
And another piece of it is
human and communitarian,
trying to build a different
sense of community.
But those themes I think
the democracy, wealth,
changing wealth and
ownership, environment,
community, participation,
those are the themes
that we're seeing develop
in many parts of the country
and in many parts of the world.
(chamber music)
- I think of the first
time the beer was served
at the Root Cellar.
I mean that feeling is tremendous,
and you realize that hey
people are enjoying this,
it's not just us.
There's a great mix of
younger folks, older folks,
women, men, those who were coming in
who might not feel that the beer
culture is currently
really speaking to them
that might feel alienated.
I think our approach helps to
kind of even that playing
field to where it's like
it's a good beverage.
- I love craft beer.
I just do.
And really in London
there's not a lot of options
right now and as soon
as I found it I'm like
I'm just happy that I
have a beer that I enjoy
and the whole co-op idea is so cool.
I've actually never experienced
that in a beer-wise.
- The big breweries out there who are,
they're sales and volume
and that's their market.
The more they can sell the better.
- There's a lot of beers, you drink one
and it tastes the same as
the other and these ones...
When you look down even
the colors are different,
the flavors are different,
it's worth supporting, yeah.
- When they name some of their beers,
you recognize the name of
it was the Spriggit Stout.
These are farms that I grew
up around the corner from.
They're bringing in local ingredients
and making a fantastic beer with it.
There's, there's morality
to their business.
Like these guys aren't gonna make it rich,
that's not the point of their business.
They're providing a good
beer for the community,
making jobs in the community.
It's a fantastic way to kinda go about it.
- We've known for decades
that if you circulate money
and materials in a local economy,
you get these multiplier effects.
By circulating money and
materials and information
in a local economy,
you're gonna be more in alignment
with the regenerative
process that actually
run, you know, it's the
way the world works.
- What I really love about that
kind of community engagement
is our neighborhood tart.
So, it was a wheat base with rhubarb,
and that rhubarb came
from old east village.
So, we had somebody take up the cause,
she went around
and just chats on the street
trying to find rhubarb
in people's backyards.
We got a ton of it,
we threw it into the brew,
it was really tasty,
and I think for us it again just...
it's a lot of fun.
I mean, beer can be a lot of fun.
Right now we brew an
incredibly inefficient beer.
It is not a turn key process.
It is not pressing a few
buttons and things work.
It is a labor of love, but it
is a lot of labor right now.
And so, we're hoping to
streamline some of those processes
by an expansion so, that we can focus on
the kind of value that we feel
our beer is bringing as well.
- The hops for the next
one are sitting over there
with the Irish moss in the latest edition.
- Brewing is, it's an
economy to scale thing.
It takes largely the same amount of labor
to produce one barrel of beer
as it does to produce
10 times that amount.
- The London Brewing
Co-op at its current size,
it fiscally doesn't work.
So, we need to scale up.
And in order to scale
up we need more space,
we need,
well, resources, time, energy, to do that.
We're gonna need some
investors, willing investors
to believe in the co-op model,
believe in our product,
and believe in a local food movement.
- I don't know that Josie's
ever been down here.
- Okay.
- So, I think a lot--
- [David] Is demonstrating what works?
- What's here.
- We know what the expansion
looks like, 225 to 250.
That's not including a purchase.
Have I got an investment
opportunity for you,
and in the first year
you'll double your money.
- Nice to see you.
- Yeah good to see you.
Thanks for joining us.
- Thanks for having us in your business.
- If you're up for it, love to chat about
what we've done here,
and maybe where we could
go into the future.
Financing in part may come
from Londoners who support
our vision and our dream.
And we want it to be angel
or patient investment
where they believe in the
purpose of what we're doing,
not just the fiscal return
that they will receive.
- I think certainly those
short-term goals that
the expansion of the brewery system
that would be in a lease situation.
- So, it's specific investors
that we're looking for who
understand our vision and believe in it.
- And that'll include
doing the renovations
in the next building,
moving the brewery there
and having it up and going?
Okay.
- [David] Yeah we'll get
that to you certainly.
- [Josie] Yeah absolutely,
and if you have any questions,
anything putting into it just let me know.
Yeah absolutely.
- Fantastic yeah.
- It drives me nuts when
I start talking this way
and people ah you're a
socialist or you're a communist.
This has nothing to do with,
this has nothing to do with
socialism versus capitalism.
This is how real systems
in the real world work,
and that's physics and biology and energy.
Everything is energy.
This is the way it works from a tornado,
to boiling water in a pot,
to insects, to entire ecosystems,
to human bodies, to human consciousness,
to the entire universe itself
is a learning, living system.
(mellow music)
- We are in Whistler, BC at
the Impact Economy Summit.
We've been trying to cook
a new economic model for
the citizen media ecosystem.
There's a lot of energy in
the room with ups and downs,
which is normal for this kind of
interactions, discussions,
and working together.
So, this is building bridges, right.
Building bridges between the open world
and the classical world
so, that you, we can establish
these flows of resources
in this process of metamorphosis.
We can't just start building
from scratch from nothing.
We are within the system,
and by establishing these
interfaces and the trust,
we can allow these resources to flow.
- This is not in any way a
classical business right?
This is not around a corporation
that wants to maximize
profit for its shareholders.
- I see traditional corporations as boxes.
So, there are spaces of confinement
that limits you in what you wanna do.
Let's say you have a project
and you go to a corporation,
and the question is do we have the budget,
or the budget, that number is a
parameter that confines you.
Do we have the skills?
So, essentially you're looking in a box
and you see what's in there?
How much money we have,
how much people we have.
So, NASA is doing a lot of prizes
and this is competitive crowd sourcing.
You see you have a prize, you
have a project, and you say,
alright who comes up with the best design,
they get the prize.
And there's a lot of redundancy,
and everyone spends money
for their own prototyping,
and for delivering something,
and then you have one winner
and the rest are losers,
and the only thing they take
home is the experience, right?
So, with the value
accounting system, we say,
well why don't you collaborate,
and log your contributions,
financial materials, time,
everything you put in there,
and then the prize you share it
according to everyone's contribution.
Okay, so you turn
competitive crowd sourcing
into collaborative crowd sourcing.
- What you're building
is a set of businesses
that feed the community.
'Cause this is a real paradigm
shift what you're doing.
This is not capitalism as we know it,
this is something entirely different.
- [Tibi] Yes.
- Then it's clear that this is really
another way to go for me.
This is the kind of answer
to a big problem that
we have today, which is
you don't get paid for
things you like to do,
you only get paid for the
things you don't like to do.
So, I think the system
that is actually able
to create livelihoods
without destroying the planet
and without creating social strife
is the one that eventually
hopefully has to win out,
because otherwise we're all doomed anyway.
- [Woman] If everyone
wants to take their seats,
that would be lovely.
- I will go home with a positive message,
that what we're doing is important,
that it's perceived as important,
which is a validation of what we do.
That's why I live for
these kinds of moments.
This is the currency I'm looking for.
I met some people that said
you Tibi, you can't fail,
because you've been there
and you've paved the way,
and if Sensorica fails,
then it sends this message.
Then I said, holy shit,
so, now I'm kind of
trapped with all this responsibility
to show that yes it can be done.
Everything is converging towards
a more collaborative economy for sure.
And when you free people
economically, they're free.
(upbeat music)
(tape rips)
I like that noise.
The tape,
it's like you're moving man.
The actual lab space that we
have now is pretty packed.
There's a lot of people
so, very crowded.
It's kind of tough on us to have to move,
but it's something that we have to do,
and we're pretty tired.
We're pretty drained.
There's a new chapter for Sensorica.
We are really coming out.
We're getting exposed downtown Montreal.
I see myself as part of the Montreal
new economy set up.
We're taking over guys.
The belly of the beast.
Visibility and presence,
legitimacy, right in people's face.
When it's time for you to go,
you look back and you're
not gonna count your money
or your material possessions.
I think the things that will give you
more satisfaction is do I leave a trace?
Well the greatest hope for the
collaborative economy is to
have this
smooth transition without too many bumps,
because we can feel that we're frustrating
the losers,
and they're powerful.
(dramatic music)
- There's no land.
I'm hoping that we're gonna get
some acreage in the middle of a park
that has to be developed here.
We need a permanent location.
We need multiple locations,
but we need one permanent location
to replace Pacific when
the via ducts come down.
We need
more people who can
really carry the workload.
I think eventually we could,
if people felt that incentive,
that they had something at
stake beyond their hourly wage,
develop something that was,
did return something to our
staff, but we're not there yet.
I want them to come to work
because they're working
for themselves, you know.
They're working for their own healing,
and for a community of farmers and eaters
that surround it, you know?
I want them to feel
that sense of ownership.
(mellow music)
I think it's probably
better than stock options or
shared ownership or anything.
I mean we've had this
idea of a cooperative,
turning this into a
workers' owned cooperative.
But the truth is what
would they be owning?
There's nothing to own.
What we can offer
is this shared experience of what happens
in the process of doing this work.
- Okay. Oh awesome.
I wanna retire here.
I'm 56, I'll be 57 November,
and this is it for me.
I think it's my last
stop, if we last that long
this is my last stop and I'm hoping we do.
All we need is boxes.
We can fill the boxes,
we will put out whatever
we need the boxes.
We need infrastructure,
if we get the infrastructure,
we will fill them up and we'll...
We're good, we really are good.
- Here's what the garden kinda
taught me, if you're
not gonna help yourself,
it's pretty hard for
other people to help ya.
They can't.
Like, you know what I mean?
If you're not willing to do it,
why should they invest all the time
and fucking spinning their wheels?
Man, if I didn't have this job,
where would I be in the last 3 years?
Like think about it, right.
Dead,
in an alley shooting up,
or in a penitentiary.
Those are my three options.
Sole Food saved my life, right?
What else can I say, it did.
Over the carrot or over the leaves?
- Over the carrots on the first one,
then over the leaves on the rest.
- For me at this stage in my life,
this is value to me.
Spending time here with my friends,
feeling good about myself.
Being able to close my eyes at night,
saying I didn't hurt anybody today.
I did maybe a couple good things.
That's value to me.
(mellow music)
- So, what is real wealth?
Well let me tell you what it's not.
It's not money,
but you know there are
people going around saying
we need a new theory of value.
So, we don't really know what that is.
I can rattle off a few ideas.
So, obviously
fresh air to breathe,
clean water to drink,
access to clean food,
family, friendships, community,
art, beauty is obviously
what we know is real wealth.
- I think that's a big thing, too,
with the cooperative is that
the cooperative shifts with the needs
of its workers,
not just with the needs
of the end product.
(mellow music)
I think the five of us
I imagine soon won't be the five of us
from a you know worker owner perspective.
I think really we wanna see
that full realization of the cooperative,
so, that we can bring in new workers who
have the same values that we do
so, that when people come into work,
it's 'cause they wanna be there.
It's 'cause they know they're part of
kind of a larger movement,
and it's not
to the detriment of who they are.
- Of course, the timing is
hilarious (laughs),
'cause I don't know,
is it legal to have
babies brew beer for us?
I don't think so.
- No, but babies with craft
beer marketing is really cute.
(mellow music)
(chamber music)
- We'll never make really good progress
until we realize that
it's not a chore to get there.
You know you don't have to
have a really unenjoyable
life in service to this cause.
It's gotta be fun right?
I mean, fundamentally it
actually needs to be enjoyable.
Just taking that approach
to thinking about how we do activism,
how we do social change,
how we organize our work,
I think it's one of the most powerful
levers of social change.
- I don't think we're gonna
wake up one day and say,
we're now in a regenerative economy.
How did we know we were
in the enlightenment?
This is a lifetimes transition
and the challenge is are
we gonna screw this up
before we make the transition?
The symptoms that we feel
will lighten.
It will feel different.
It will feel healthy.
And then we'll say wow, it feels better.
- It's a very moving period of history,
potentially big things can happen.
I think we are at a moment maybe,
always a maybe, that we
are laying the groundwork
for potentially,
not only transformation but
irreversible transformation.
That's a big deal in history.
A very interesting time.
(chamber music)